finale time god I can't believe it it's
been like such a road yeah to think that
this is it yes there's DLC to this game
but maybe we'll save that for down the
road if we keep playing but I think yeah
this will be the end of the game this
episode right unless you really really
screwed up no I think even if you do
that you'll still have like an hour and
a half left yeah cuz when we started
this endeavor the original promise was
just beginning to end of the numbered
series like that was that was the
promise and we have done that I think
almost as the you just got back to kind
of the mansion grounds ish after the
tanker after you Mia found Ethan and
broke him out and then Mia kind of
gotten like got take taken over by the
girl the little girl Evelyn right and I
remember like the last one especially
was such a huge change in terms of like
what I thought this game was like I
thought this game was going to like live
and die within that mansion and it was
gonna be about getting out and getting
away from this like massive like evil
family but now after there was this
cutscene where the dad seemed a lil
endearing and was just trying
he was like save us now I'm like kind of
thrown for a loop with who the bad
person is I mean even the kid who is
definitely like not a good person but
she's just a kid so it's really hard for
me to know who's bad at this stage I'm
very confused and it's a good game I
it's just it really threw me for a loop
alright so I have a lot of [ __ ] I would
take the machine gun okay and like a
strong camp Luud I have three those I
have eight remote bombs which have been
really handy and I've just really
enjoyed having them because they're like
super fun to use so I might keep that no
no MPM hand guns better or that 45 you
had I don't know I think the the 45 is
better
the m-19 up top the m-19 is better than
them 21 shotgun I would also bring okay
okay I don't think you'll need a grenade
launcher yet and probably say that for
the inevitable final boss fight I'm
gonna take the knife just because it's
good to you know kill people with
anything else I could take some herbs I
mean bring ammo handgun machine gun
shotgun shells give two separate handgun
ammo things thirteen can I combine them
yeah you should it should unless thirty
the max I think it's just because it
might be aim from be as handgun will
take 30 days and that's yeah yeah I
don't think you need 2030 okay mmm
anything else
machine gun maybe one you have a lot of
strong chem fluids I do I'm gonna
lockpick - I do yeah oh I do that might
come in handy
no it's kinda keep it here and then we
can there will be another safe box how
about this dummy finger I could take
another strong can do that do I need to
yeah just you got a bunch wait here we
go and you saw that photograph last time
of the umbrella logoed helicopter um
wait look at that yes to the left
looking like that's creepy
little girls like cloaks these three
black clothes been a hard hit and then a
hard hat hard hats everywhere oh yeah
they say you're going into the salt
mines I don't remember that that was
that's kind of what I you heard there's
a radio transmission it's not like we
heard that Lucas escape to the salt
mines and then there was this male voice
said oh I'm gonna go after him and and
then there was like oh Alpha Team this
is Bravo Team calling in so like you
know there's an alpha and Bravo Team
kind of like the first resin evils right
and to investigate shoot to kill the
little girl oh one minor thing that I
don't think you would see there is some
sort of item around the edge of the
shack outside okay I used
psychostimulants last time I played
should I do that it's like right up
against the check yeah I think around
back maybe you're on the ground
hey oh how do i I have to do that right
yeah I don't think I'll need remote
bombs now you can put that left side
oops oops yeah
Magnum I don't have a magnet you might
as well put that back in the box
I think I will cuz I have a lot of stuff
look on the ground like I'll round the
edge of the I don't think it was that
Magnum ammo I was thinking maybe it's on
the other side
that's it maybe I was thinking about the
bobblehead okay
sorry mentally I'm like where am i okay
so I'll put these this back but one of
the strong ones back I think the regular
is good okay there we go here we go
pull me out feel good have a full
inventory again yes I mean say box
whatever and even a gun remember cuz if
there were times we're like I didn't
have anything yeah it's so debilitating
- oh my god no bombs might be in so I'm
gonna put the remote bombs back okay
there we go
there's so many of them you put that in
the water I wondered oh yeah I guess so
oh [ __ ] I didn't go very well
there's not enough room yeah
wait where is he oh there he is they're
just like letting it all hang out now oh
my got me oh I thought I did it I felt
really confident I think I'm still on
Green that's a bummer though I really
thought I dodged I felt I felt a strong
Juke there but it's not that Resident 3
nemesis juking right look at that you're
letting it all hang out gotcha oh I got
him
[ __ ] actually went through a lot of ammo
just now and you've got a lot oh my god
where's he going just kind of look like
resonable for this area industrial mix
there is a bunch of him yeah he's still
alive no he's not
it's probably more yeah I don't know
where that one came from got me good
little secret little secret nook
[Music]
there's some foxes back here
strong chem that's good thought you
could get away and it wasn't maggots
everything's coming up millhouse this is
going well she's got ammo handgun ammo
[Music]
I'll leave it as is for now I think I'm
okay okay so
yeah this expense on whether the
elevator will bring you up or down oh
yeah um down because there's nothing up
there
I was also joking is it's a resin evil
oh well
president before the elevator brought
you out that tower thought you were
being sincere against someone someone
who's like catching up on episodes tweet
at us about the the errant grenade
incident oh yeah that was so funny
I like when people so Christmastime
there's this wonderful time where people
typically have the time ray because
you're hanging out and not as many
people have to work and you can kind of
delve through all this old content so we
see a huge uptick in views because
people are just hanging out and watching
stuff
we had people like watching videos that
were much older right from Resident Evil
4 in the incident where I had maybe 1%
of health and I didn't even look it
wasn't even showing up on your health
part and I had like one grenade and you
said just don't throw it off and I was
like okay flashbang I think it
immediately threw it off the edge
survive but I did survive all too well
just checking my six here oh no
[ __ ] those are air conditioning units
sir what would you like to know about
them
I was wondering there I was on it yeah
they're pulling out all the stops right
now aren't they okay oh oh we're back to
this are we well remember the male voice
said Lucas escaped to the mines right
can I just shoot it no I'm well I mean
like no cuz you can use them I'm gonna
say what if something else falls from
the ceiling well if it's be careful of I
don't know where that one's going to
crouch probably be a good rule of thumb
in this room oh also someone in the
comments mentioned that you know Lucas
part at least if you scratch next to one
of the boxes and you can if you don't
hear a ticking it's not booby-trapped
but you can hear the ticking if it is
next to one of these now the boxes to
see if every trap yeah oh I wish I knew
that unless they're trolling us in that
case we'll find out soon but because
there's booby traps it's probably safe
to try that
all right there's an orchestra coming
from that box
what does that mean oh is that a farty
blow to you man you don't know nice oh
crap
wait can you feel the other one for this
do you want oh like oh why do you keep
doing Mike was running on accident
oh there's two let them come oh he's a
bunch where is it there's another one I
think both of them there is and there he
is and there is all right cool after
this let's see if we can hear some yeah
I was like accidentally running I
thought maybe you could Crouch run you
know like where you squat but you didn't
even check to see first I forgot I don't
know if they are booby-trapped in the
second but because there's tripwires it
might well I forgot yeah it's it forgot
to almost you almost forgot to crouch
under that wire earlier - alright I will
listen to this one sounds like you're
good oh okay
burner fuel you needed that definitely
don't need it probably drop it if you
want I'll hold on to it until I don't
want it okay so I think there is oh [ __ ]
okay
can I stand now alright let's change
into something a little bit more
comfortable so I just want to know where
the wire is for this okay it's right
there so what I'll do is I can crawl
back if I have to so I can't come back
mayhaps resi ol five there's a section
where we're in the mines and then it was
like that it was me and you against a
ton of people in the rocket not osos
really go for can hear them whatever
borrows virus I don't know but [ __ ] they
know how I feel about multiple
directions I'm gonna go this way first
hey Adam sorry there's probably a safe
room coming up I got a full slot baby I
was drop the burner fee all over them
bagging round oh definitely weights with
just one bullet so misleading cuz the
picture has five in it no um okay so
well if you had picked if you pick up a
bunch of other ones it'll stack on that
image and tell you there's but yeah I
never notice that before with when you
throw bombs are like jugs of oh right
I said man they came out of nowhere I
thought I heard them and then I was like
[ __ ] that's what I was saying the remote
pounds you can gasoline juggling around
these tell me where did they come from
outer space
oh my brain I like I heard them I think
okay so they wait judges this whole
section again
nice alright
that sucks let's just not die this time
yeah you don't back up all the way out
here this time either yeah I'll just
circle I forget where they come from
though did they come from over here I
guess so
yeah because you were listening at that
box I think they come from the tunnel
yep
I don't think it's gonna kill him but
that makes one well
oh it did
[Music]
sweet remember you yeah still got the
one of the entrance be funny for this
procedural and sometimes these are booby
traps oh I hate that [ __ ] divinity is
like that and sometimes you do a lot for
no you do a lot and it's like nothing
you know there's like an orange in the
box you're like that's some [ __ ] cuz I
put all that effort into it do you beat
that game ah no because I lost the save
so I started over and it's very long but
I'm very I'm pretty far
I'm the most intimidating League deep
game it's very deep but it's very good I
absolutely love it but it's taking me a
lot longer to beat it this time around I
also can't play video games during the
day anymore yeah except for now oh right
now like literally now cuz that was our
number 5 game of the year
I think it was my number it was high
like - maybe it was very high for me
this was for 3 was mario odyssey - would
have been persona and then one would
Zelda sorry I'm just trying to like
mentally come to terms with it because
these guys killed me really fast so I
think I need a better maybe a shot a lot
of shotgun shotgun whose be good this is
the upgraded shotgun also
I'm trying to think if you even need to
pick up this Magnum round well I don't
even think you're gonna find another you
can't wait where's the burner fuel it
was in you got an herb in the box and
stuff oh so is change the items are
procedural I'm talking about it'd be
funny if sometimes that one was
booby-trapped sometimes [ __ ] does he
come from because they came from behind
me you were there maybe when you turn
around after getting this maybe I just
don't know how I didn't see it oh they
came from die okay I don't know no
that's where you came from
yeah oh they did come some [ __ ] Oh
[Music]
[Music]
well now you know where they're coming
from so there's a mole problem or
something you think Ethan would be
faster every loading well he you've
upgraded in twice but I blame him
that's so bad what bad [ __ ] I normally
can do it on the second trial [ __ ] I'm
very disappointed myself just don't want
it to end you know [ __ ] you got it down
this time use five bullets I thought you
said a fourth all right I feel like I've
been too optimistic this whole game as
opposed to like actually should go this
way I think because I get them earlier
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
way
we'll make sure he goes that way
okay let's do this whole section again
now I hope you don't get burn fuel
that's good all right so let's talk
about this I can even put a remote bomb
down in advance like that's that's how
much I know about this section now so
there's like put it at the yeah there's
like no [ __ ] reason to do this also
I'm sick of doing it like right in the
middle of here and they're like here
yeah because they come out of this one
and the one that you came out of yeah
just make sure you're not standing on it
need that name mmm worse things have
happened okay so go get and then shotgun
okay so
seekers out there go left and then get
ready is that name
okay they both come out I'm like that
simple sweet that one much better
[Music]
bonus bonus house what's up it's gonna
say you yours riding his blood thirst
I'm not doing this section again see
it's an upgraded shotgun in terms of
damage but smaller all right I'm feeling
it slower rate of fire or whatever you
want to say smaller magazine it's not
magazine but you get what I'm saying
smaller vogue Vanity Fair yeah me I'm
back so hurry but it's like that be a
lesson eat Leslie Nielsen joke and a war
movie like quick hand me another mag I'm
out and then he just gives him like Us
Weekly he reads a feature in the middle
of a firefight no I mean a clip and then
he gives him like a little paper but
where
you're outta here take a hike
where
hey guys right here I'm not even gonna
say it but you know what I mm-hmm nice
shooting Thanks I can handle shotguns
because they're really hard to miss with
those as disproven by the last time you
came oh my goodness that was so sad -
two deaths but this time I got it
what is this this is a dead end
Oh do I push this okay that's nice
never play timesplitters 2 there's a
Wild West level where you pushing around
exposed parts happiness so big my
favorites checking my six check my 9
mm-hmm all right I'm not giving you
coffee anymore oh sorry no there's a
good though check out the wild west
entice boaters to theme it's really good
song because you go through different
time periods it's a shooter set in
different time periods like gangster
Chicago 90s Russia
nothing sci-fi I forget what I'm doing
down here
like I guess I'm killing the brother
this is also like according that map in
the safehouse this is the quickest way
back to the mansion I think Oh God at
least it saved
this looks like a nice little safety
corner look that that was a while ago
that looks like a bomb mm-hmm I'm gonna
shoot that yeah it's over here
that's gotta be booby-trapped
for the record I'm basing that ticking
thing entirely off one comment great
well they have been right most of the
time I don't think that one time when we
went really far backwards to go get
something and nothing was there what I
can't remember there was just a time oh
god I forgot I'm pretty sure I heard
ticking we'll never know because I'm
dumb [ __ ] I forgot oh I'll play this
game I want to play this game to VR soon
again I'm so disappointed with myself
this is the same room I don't think so
come on J yeah that's probably gonna
trigger some sort of cutscene yeah super
round go ahead what are they bathing in
thanks to you guys it's been about a
week since my head's been clear and back
to normal and she still thinks she's got
me you guys really need to work on
fixing that not only does she look like
a little kid but she's about as stupid
as 1 2 oh wait mom and dad are still
totally under though what I was
wondering is this whole family obsession
something you guys programmed into her
it's kind of [ __ ] up that [ __ ] Mia is
still somewhere in between
evie lala land and reality she gets
pretty violent so I locked her up in a
Cell I thought maybe Evelyn would get
mad since Mia is her favorite but she
doesn't seem to care she's actually goes
and visits her she thinks me is her
mommy like I said your bio weapon is
[ __ ] up
Evelyn's family obsession is getting out
of hand she's making everyone kidnap
more and more [ __ ] off the street to
add to her freak show of a family maybe
she's getting tired of me and not coming
around but it's a pain in the ass for me
because I got to clean up the mess
whenever someone new comes along by the
way Evie's sick or something
her skin's getting all wrinkly and she's
getting gray hairs is that supposed to
happen it's almost like she's getting
old not only does she look like a little
kid but she's a stupidest one so she's
not a little kid I guess I think
bio-organic is redundant but you get one
new infection report now read it closer
oh okay no ex president write this do
you report details the symptoms that
appear when a bacterium grows inside of
the e-series
ii series like t virus B virus be sure
to read this document the mold ingests
nutrients from the subjects body to
propagate itself and slowly takes over
cells within the body it's a cancer
pretty much as a side effect the
injected subject gains remarkable
regenerative abilities we removed arms
and legs and then they could just take
them once the mold reaches the brain the
subjects thoughts become in tune with
those of you eseries the subject starts
to hear things under and experience
hallucinations as soon comes under a
complete control the host loses sense
after every cell in the body has been
taken over the subject loses their human
form physical mutations differ from case
to case but all result in him or her
acquiring incredible physical strength
okay
so we're learning a bit about the molded
that's the girl it looks like they did
inject it into an actual little girl so
wait she died all right five minutes
after dose vomiting eseries dosage test
Oh Lord
who's that saying target acquired did
the serum I don't know
hey see this see this
wait is this where I put this think so
I should have read this first destroy
cells of any it's just it means destroy
that eseries asset evelyn probably
pretty much oh so what's that that's the
antidote for me now to destroy the you
are you say you already checked yourself
with an antidote this is to destroy the
asset got it destroy cells of any
subject okay so so i inject the little
girl with that yeah to kill her got it
I feel like I need to heal come on
yellow but I'm a bit concerned the
project was instigated in 2000 next this
enemies into allies we wonder we had the
blank and even blanks blank organization
chomping at the bit to get on board
somebody's crossed this out blah blah
blah blah blah candidates a through D
now we are on preparation each a common
appearance was selected for bio weapons
ten-year-old girl to ensure ease of
blending with urban refugee population
oh [ __ ] it's like really heartless
mm-hmm still have a lot to learn oh so
that's why you were seeing her as Mia
when she wasn't really there okay
phantom Evelyn
self-mutilation is an attack
psychological shock so the body blanks
is this like a game where I'm supposed
to guess that word maybe is redacted
what's a 12-letter word for die mold
mold attacks oh this is a lot of text
superorganisms blah blah blah fungal
toughness that's nice
they've been made of mold it comes to
calcify it remember that's what happened
to Jack when you beat him yeah you like
calcified when I injected him with
Andrea yeah and what's her name Margaret
this is just speculation but it could be
that she instinctively understands that
a family's unit is better suited to
blending into social groups than a lone
girl she's making up for perceived lack
of love and her quarantined upbringing
parents no the other thing I just like I
need the disease a tries to protect
itself and okay I feel like this is this
is it I think all right so I'm I think I
should heal up to you what don't say it
like that yeah this is it right so
unhelpful all of a sudden you don't need
that Magnum around
well do I need these flame rounds cuz
then I need the flame thing grenade
launcher yeah you could probably get rid
of the submachine gun and bring the
grenade launcher instead yeah okay [ __ ]
you burner nobody likes you so I have a
grenade launcher first reload it just so
you get rid of the flame rounds okay
Old Faithful back in action you'll still
have one but still that's okay so okay
so I have one and then you can make a
health with that basic hemp Luud in a
herb okay okay and then I have these
remote bombs rid of those two herbs you
have so many herbs okay I have these
remote bombs do you think those are
handy yeah keep those okay and then I
should get more flame rounds like or at
least more round
it's narrower round two I think I don't
know what I have but I have other things
I have for neuro rounds and for more
flame rounds yeah okay that's good
that's good
alright now I'm gonna save take down
Evelyn well it's right there in the
title look at those old set saves those
memories some of them are really old
I've been saving over my the last one
there which is a bit nerve-wracking but
I'm pretty sure like I don't need to go
back at this point I feel confident all
right so what should I start with I'll
start with a shotgun because that makes
me feel safe and then I'll move to this
guy when I'm ready
don't just go firing off grenade
launchers willy-nilly well historically
enhanced sick yeah I don't want to go
down here go down there this looks super
dangerous does this where it came from
I hear a bubble do you hear it
underneath you maybe I mean I got bigger
problems
I kind of want to use one what a health
what are you on yellow yellow cuz y'all
like a lot of the really bad they're
really I would manually do it though so
you make sure that you doesn't use the
advanced health you have I have an
advanced oh never mind
you could heal yeah sure I mean I could
wait it's just that you know like a lot
of times the really mean ones they can
kill you in one hit get ton of [ __ ] yeah
I know it's not good
where's that bobble no not under the
stairs
where was it probably is up
hi well go back to where you were hurt
it
I don't remember your right to your left
no back keep going back right like yeah
here it's probably it's not moving away
from where it is go back to yeah
stay there now look around yeah you're
right ok do it another time
it's like [ __ ] right there I just
don't know where oh well ok here we go
[Music]
sweetheart
little little girl oh no I don't want go
in there in water
so are you hallucinating are you being
taken over or it's at her it's her uh-oh
I don't like this at all what's over
here
shotgun shells mag oh now I'm full I
know and you're gonna get those in hands
hand got around so until I told you gave
her those 14 handgun rounds right I
shouldn't have brought my regular gun I
should have bought ya be Magnum you
don't have the Magnum oh right I'm
saying you also picked up 12 enhanced
handgun rounds oh god I don't want to go
and hear it all do it why'd she stop
singing
well you knew that you were encased in
that [ __ ]
no no no no I'm not ready I'm not ready
I'm not ready
[Applause]
you should have healed I wasn't ready
there's four guys there yeah [ __ ] there
was nowhere to run goddamn it
it's my mouse I'm so bad at this there's
my mouse sort one it's got the coffee
stain on it I'm very disappointed in
myself oh you're right back here [ __ ]
what have you got scared and wasted the
neurotoxin the one of these
it
sit your stinky ass down that went
better it appears that I either like do
it or I die well that seems
wise words never spoken I doubt I can't
take that actually should I just eat
some of these it's not gonna free up
space at all not even healing well
oh I see and now I'm on green gotcha
okay
okay sorry I'm just collecting myself
here
do not come from behind using handgun
can why I don't know just cuz you have a
lot it's taking up space and you it's
just harder to kill things
oh well bouncing why I don't know they
probably some behind you order soon no
si up I'm not kidding I'm just saying
there's no aims game
I didn't mean it that way you killed it
with what I don't know I hit a lot of
buttons at once I'm gonna tell you that
look at how busted up your gun is it's
got guts all over it
[ __ ] that was bad at least I survived
but like that the ones who like crawl
there so fast ik I get really scared and
I like panic we say let's take a couple
shots
oh [ __ ] oh my god
I like don't know where I'm going
there's three ways there's in there
there's in there let's go yeah that's
just a loop
I should have I should have looked
forgot
don't be sorry you already had some oh
you didn't get ready the machine gun
ammo did you yeah you shouldn't pick
that up come across a box I could I can
drop it if I need to no no no you're
fine
okay
am i ready I am ready okay
yes
it makes it look simple except for when
I heal on accident and then die Oh God
all right right or left here
over this way more what
look how far I've come
nope
sorry I have
please check these for ticking
don't come I think it you hear that
here it
am I crazy I think
okay it just sounds like howling I guess
yeah take that you already have 20 steak
okay wait check that box they listen to
it now maybe not you're walking don't
want that
okay are you a tool help
drop yet they're going what they're
gonna drop
wow I thought that was gonna hurt you me
too you and me both
you know there's one behind us
yeah
I am short on
well it's
oh what's that I heard it you heard it
both heard it
so many molded
this is a shotgun scenario no we're
party party dude I think I don't see it
yeah already blow to party buddy Oh God
fine
it was just fly all you can get hit
yeah
Oh Lord hey you stumbled this way fine
[Music]
you can do this 360 180 degrees heal up
[Music]
shotgun start going ham thanks
please don't on it
Oh bye
[Music]
yeah I'm running out
I'm gonna die yeah yeah yeah he's dead
and gone this [ __ ]
it's such a projectile
oh this is such an ordeal die
god that was close there's a first-aid
mat over on the crate over there I died
the first time I did that you did yep
cuz I did not expect to party well one
of them was like an extra bloated party
where around that rock to your right
unless you picked it up already I might
have I don't think you did like right
here right right now it was on this rock
I think I did okay well you also have
supplies that could last you for the
apocalypse
damn that took so much hell
I think I should make a regular and use
it what do you think how do you feel
about this decision okay and then how do
I make sure I use the right one is it
this yeah I think by default you use the
more powerful one first oh really
I'm actually not entirely sure so I
could switch to the fancy rounds should
I do that as well because I could also
save them and not load it in this gun is
the only handgun you use and then I
would recommend okay so I'm gonna do it
then mm-hmm damn it sorry I'm done I got
it we're good now and then this is done
and this is done and I didn't use those
I'm not sure if I was supposed to he's
what
rocket grenades you're ascending
ascension I'm not gonna name names but I
took a scuba-diving course uh-huh as an
elective my senior year of college
uh-huh a few years ago yeah and I got
they say how I got my scuba diving
certification and there was a football
player on that Syracuse University
football team he was a wide receiver in
my class and the instructor was telling
us he's like yeah so when you're
ascending make sure you don't inflate
your BC you're like your vest
essentially which helps you float once
you get up he's like you actually have
to kick up because if you inflated you
could ascend too quickly right your
lungs will expand and so the football
player raised his hand he's like what
does ascend mean I wasn't we all thought
he was joking but here's a long story
very serious yeah just when I said the
ascent that made my jaw my memory you
didn't notice then you must have been
like
yeah that's not I was looking for a box
if you're if you don't know what a sin
means maybe you shouldn't be putting
yourself in an environment where you
can't breathe yeah I would say like the
biggest concern with that is when you're
talk about life-and-death stuff if you
don't know the words I'd be careful with
it oh no no it's the wheelchair it's not
grandma my fighting grandma what's that
grandmas are you back in the basement
where you first were when you saw Mia I
do feel like I'm back in the house but I
don't know no oh wait isn't there that
locked door you could never get there
you are back down here yeah look can you
see yourself to the right well that's
where you would have been what's there
what's gone this is where you were at
the beginning of the game when you were
escaping Jack are you thought it was
Jack yeah zero zero no I don't want to
fight grandma I know what it's telling
you is the grandma the little kid mm-hmm
yeah she's serious no oh wait you did
have the neurotoxin so all you had to do
was go inject Rama wait and you would
have saved the whole Baker family
supposedly how come they never protected
grandma what do you be protected her
well she was like at dinner with them
like why didn't they like do something
obvious you weren't a danger to Grandma
you weren't like worried about grandma
at that time they knew like she was safe
I [ __ ] hate grandma oh he's
something about
this is the hallway where Mia first
attacked you
so this is not the mansion this is like
the guest house Oh Lord what's that not
cool wind that's gonna ring
you stupid I don't think I can hurt her
so me no likey
only over that simple listen sweetie
let's not do this your folks I don't
think that was fair you're infected you
dolt
she's taking over you open I don't see
anything in here she'll go in that door
cash cash her outside how about that
nothing three there's a door to the left
I think where she disappeared
there's here this is locked is part of
the house
right here now [ __ ] scare you little
[ __ ] no it's not as part of the demo
how should I go in there I like don't
think you should just go where she is
well according to WHO the last thing
that happened was she kiss appeared and
you walked in the direction so this is
showing what me I was here thank you
dunwood this is from the beginning
inqilab died such a broken record of you
mommy's turn to kill you Oh Lord
oh wait this used to be a room no that
was the mansion this is the first place
you want his work in was investigating
fireplace your left
trapdoor inside I have no desire to do
any of these things
you're almost there go I don't like it
yeah I remember this place this is from
the demo as well oh god shut up
Oh Lord you suck go I'm not playing
should I not have done that
sorry responsible what am i doing
weird that doll come from I just go the
same way cheese I accidentally used a
good handgun rounds on her when someone
comes at you with a chainsaw you kind of
just you know things happens
why are you go upstairs now oh is it the
Attic if you're not going up there yet
no oh
I go nowhere unless it's required you've
gone up here at SRI yeah but before
unnecessary geez ascend there's a
metaphor here coming up out of the lines
I guess
oh she's right there where look you're
right Oh No
am i fighting her now
yeah be clear go that way
how maybe you can buy that way
oh okay that hurt me okay oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna get killed here yeah guard let's
go to order and guard when that happens
yeah you gonna [ __ ] her up
yeah mice what's the hitter no just keep
don't order sweetheart
stab that little [ __ ] [ __ ] you you
she say dang you all to hell damn you
yeah I'm like actually dang oh I don't
oh my god oh my god yep
how do I got
anything anyone
hey you're doing it right but I think
you gotta check one but how do you avoid
getting eaten shoot faster jeez there's
no escaping just keep attacking her
sticks to the sides of a broom maybe
maybe cheese reload faster this time
okay yeah because you're [ __ ] killing
people don't kill people you a-hole
you'll have more friends
alright let me
all right she here
oh [ __ ] I did the thing I got it she
came for her eyes too
you stop it
oh [ __ ] that's not what I meant to do
I'm working on it
[ __ ] [ __ ]
am i doing okay I think you just had to
avoid getting killed it oh [ __ ] cell
phone Bravo teams Mikey hey he's back in
the finale
oh Lord get up magnet brother yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] her up she smashed my relays
everything I'm gonna die New Deal or No
come on lady has he kept her she kept
hurting me you know
yeah okay just better
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] up what
yeah can I Euler unknown
alpha Bravo Albert Wesker hey use it
what is it you're the magnet playtime
loaded with the [ __ ] [ __ ]
Yeah right in your freaking I just
calcifying yeah tree trunk in touch hi
you would now [ __ ] do I have legs
somebody toss me that
tranquilizer gun thing thank God yeah
that was nice well she did hey it's my
buddy there's a bunch of them they
cloned them
it's Mike a Mike be Mike seen Mike D and
Mikey hello
I'm Redfield oh my god I'm glad we found
you
Chris the [ __ ] took you guys so long
but a call back
not even a call back what a fan sir
every scene moment yeah it's nice though
I love that he had to clarify though cuz
they changed his look so much yeah
oh wow she lived you made it yeah they
must I think they got went to the barge
first did I
[Music]
don't they say that when one door closes
another opens well a door closed tonight
thanks Ethan and what a long night it
was but not just for me me and I weren't
the only victims here so were the bakers
that was that thing Evelyn who made them
that way
but now everyone's dead
and these guys are here to clean up the
mess are they though apparently they're
good now I just come to terms with
losing me and now she's back and wants
to start over but all this behind us
I don't know though maybe this is where
the next door opens to be continued and
resume with me
[Music]
seven games later in an hour year and
maybe almost according to plan we
weren't a year late yeah because we were
supposed to play this game when it came
out yeah so what's this credits I think
[Music]
that was good
mm-hmm you know it wasn't as long as I
thought it would be how long was that D
finale the whole game um I don't know I
think it's a good length 11 hours maybe
that's not to say that I think I wish it
was longer I just I think I expected it
to be longer but I'm very satisfied with
the amount of we did it in 10 episodes I
think a few of them won over an hour it
probably took you like 13 14 hours yeah
that was a very good game
so there's DLCs yeah there's not a hero
which is so member you heard Chris over
the radio saying I'm going to look for
Lucas so from chronologically I believe
before he came to yeah yeah before he
came to save you just now or 30 that gun
he was hunting Lucas in the Salt Mines
and then there's Zoey's end so you know
how you could choose between Zoey and
Mia
yes canonically like you can pick either
one but like it's almost like you're
play Metro 2033 at the end you could
choose whether to nuke the things or
save them yeah it's kind of like that
where there's two choices but the
developer Capcom expect it not even
expected like they in Cannon you save
Mia
so Zoe's end is another DLC when you
play her uncle who lives kind of near
buying the Bayou
okay and he heard about all this
happening and came to save Zoe because
you don't know what happened to Zoe or
Lucas at this point right like they're
just they're just gone there's like no
conclusion yeah so in the DLC there's
also other DLC there's like an escape
room there's there's one there's an
escape room where you are one of the
other victims of the Baker's and you're
trying to get out of it's terrifying
like I think we'll have to do it at some
point maybe Oh so that's resident can
evil that's seven that's the end of the
numbered series yeah we're still
figuring out I know a lot of people are
wondering what
you
turn this down what I think they're
telling they were going to decode
Veronica zero code Veronica is sounds
really good people are saying it's very
good it's tough that's gonna be the
hardest that's like the hardest one
period especially after these well it's
like there's a gut-check like a few
hours like halfway through that you can
really [ __ ] yourself over here not
prepared for it like start getting the
game over [ __ ] over jeez
but yeah people are asking us to do that
people are snoozed to do resonable zero
the DLC for this game which we should at
some point if we do do bonus stuff okay
I'd say we could do it it does add on to
the story that's but I think you got the
resident 7 experience I feel like I have
a Resident Evil experience I feel like
now after seven games I have a pretty
good understanding of yeah all of the
residences of the evils we've been
talking about like other stuff want to
do like a cuz you did Claire does he
will remake yes
I'm sorry Jill and then yeah and
resonable tweeted leon did you or did
you do Claire you did Leon so we were
talking about doing a Claire beat
scenario we're talking about doing code
Veronica's zero maybe like the original
Resident Evil like I wanted we don't
you'll see of this game too
yeah yeah you know like maybe you come
back to that so we can go back and like
I'm pretty interested in seeing what
happens to the brother Lucas Lucas oh
and you play ask Chris by the way Oh
interesting and it's kind of more
action-oriented like you saw he had an
assault rifle and smoke grenades and gas
masks and [ __ ] cool yeah yeah that's
cool so we'll let people know if we
figure stuff out yeah revelations
revelations 1 2 it would be fun I'd like
to keep going once we commit to what
we're gonna play next we'll stick to it
like we have been like maybe we'll take
like a week break but it's like let's do
it every week just like we have been
once we commit to which game we're gonna
play next because resonable revelations
on the switch now to one ante and those
are two is co-op and one is pretty good
your join here my final ordered list of
the number ones yeah okay
so remake yeah it's mine I almost want
to say seven it's very very good
that'd be my number two or three yeah I
think it's up there I'm gonna say yeah I
think I'm gonna say seven seven four
yeah um - mm-hmm
three mm-hmm six five okay
six five yeah I think a lot of people
would [ __ ] hate five I don't like
clinics either I think six cooperatively
probably bumped it up a above five yeah
it's fun playing with you like five is
so and maybe it's just the jolt from
four but five was just like such a drag
I couldn't I didn't want to come here I
didn't want to like I'm a game spot like
I just couldn't get into it yeah our
relationship wavered a few times we got
mad at each other we fought well you
kill me a few times
well you [ __ ] stop playing that one
time oh my god anyway so that's way no
hold on hold on man what are your
favorite moments from there out the
series we talked about the elevator
earlier for to recap yeah apologies to
those who have not who just watched her
the new seven don't know ready before I
was playing your health was so low that
the red wasn't even showing up like the
health bar was empty I was one of my
favorite moments ever I would have to
say one of the highlights was the spider
boss of seven me what a [ __ ]
terrifying boss I think it's the
scariest episode ever shooting that
grenade on accident because like I was
so scared I was so scared
well you also hit the mosquito perfectly
got him
there was a time in think one or remake
had a lot of really good scares for me
like when the dogs jumped through the
window there's a little scare
and we should definitely play the
original one if we're gonna play bonus
games we should do the original ps1
version the very first Walker guy who
was like walking on a ceiling like
that scared me so bad because I've never
seen anything like that before and then
in three the first time the
what's-his-name the nemesis that gay man
kept finding me roadblocks and I
couldn't get away from him I mean
there's so many highlights and then none
from five insects like I hate none from
five and six no I don't like almost any
part of those games like I've never
liked what a colony though so we didn't
do Jake oh we need to Jake's campaign at
some point hopefully do bonus stuff
oh the fish from four was really fun
when you're like oh like the Lago you're
like jet ski on the back of them and
stuff dodo not jet skiing
you're just waterskiing on the back of
him and you're like no you're not it's
you you harpoon him and they pull the
boat that be you jet ski at the end of
the game oh yeah I don't like what
everybody it's like too hard and then I
think over time Joe that's why seven is
better than four is because even though
four is iconic because it like does all
these new innovative things it has all
these problems whereas like seven I
can't really tell you a lot of problems
of that game that's this is a very well
made game there's no errors where I'm
like what a bad judgment call by the
game designers like the worst thing is
maybe like a boss fight that's just not
that interesting yeah but nothing that
I'm not mad about like I who's your
favorite resonable character to date
like whether they're dumb or endearing
or badass I mean Jill's pretty badass
yeah I just so you played as Jill twice
in resume three and remake I just like
her I think she's pretty solid she keeps
her [ __ ] together so you never played
his Claire Redfield have you
I don't think so she would be the Beast
scenario and then he played his Leone
twice well and in six Kristen five and
one and no you didn't playing in one you
played Jill
so Jill's and resonable revelations oh
my favorite character is the guy that
dies in remake when he's like sorry
about your burger
today that was reasonable - looks like
your party's been canceled yeah that was
nice chief looks like your party's
canceled yeah a fan-favorite is Barry he
comes back and revelations
- yeah he's actually I want to throw
this time quick
so Loras Kelly their PR manager from
Capcom Europe and here we can see our
good friend Stephanie Palermo Patrick
Terry Terry
he's been on dead air our old Alicia Kim
- he's just a friend of ours you know
like when you used to live with him yeah
Michael on he's from Game Informer and
he's he came on our extra life stuff all
the time you watch this - probably
probably mentioned him before yeah they
they know they also hosted GameSpot in
Osaka when we were shooting a behind the
scenes making this game she can watch
that tomorrow tomorrow and Adam in the
UK and I kind of helped out but anyway
dad Knievel well that is Canadian people
updated it took you long enough
but yeah well keep people updated on
where and when and hopefully if we do
bonus stuff the goal is to do it we just
want to commit to it I don't want to do
it and then like only do it like once a
month right like it's like we have to
commit the weeks to it and do it like
we've been doing these but yeah that was
great mm-hmm that's seven Resident Evil
games thank you guys so much for going
on this journey with us it was kind of a
weird thing when we even initially
discussed doing this right like it was
such a weird idea to play all seven
games in series and make sure that we
dedicated the time to it and then in
that time because it took so long I
changed jobs I don't even work here
anymore and we I like asked if I could
still do this and GameSpot was really
cool and they like let me keep doing it
and so his twitch and was I still had
editorial when we started this or was
already we're moving over and this whole
thing like so much has happened in our
lives over the course of like the last
year in two months but we still did it
we bit we beat every resident evil'
supposed to live in San Francisco we
still live here and thank you guys for
joining us this really long journey
and you know if you if you just came for
seven there's six other games that we've
been playing through and hopefully we'll
keep we'll keep playing we're not done
yet so thank you guys for sticking with
us thus far it's been really fun it's
been a really good journey
you head us up on Twitter or in the
youtube comments or you tell us with the
best Knievel moment was for you Emma
Hardy and Mary Kish you guys can find us
on Twitter and hang out with us and
suggest other things for us to do but
thank you very much it's been good yeah
god I'm so sick of you it's bittersweet
it's it's it's sweet I'm just kidding
yeah it's